[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
for sure
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and I'll be one of your guides for
today's Nintendo Direct I'm yoshiaki
koizumi and I'll also be joining today
that was the latest trailer for The
Hidden Treasure of area zero the paid
DLC for the Pokemon scarlet and Pokemon
Violet games the first half of the
trailer took place at a festival in the
countryside
while the second half seemed to be in a
completely different location a
futuristic Academy in the middle of the
ocean
[Music]
more details on this DLC will be
available in the future
and after today's Nintendo Direct a
special event will be held in Pokemon
scarlet and Pokemon Violet we hope
you'll participate in it
okay let's see our first batch of
headlines
it's a supersonic Squad of superstars
Sonic and friends are spin dashing into
a brand new 2D side-scrolling game Sonic
Superstars 12 brand new zones away
speed through beautiful worlds as Sonic
take to the sky the skies as Tails
scale walls and glide as knuckles or
swing a powerful Hammer as Amy Rose
[Music]
by harnessing the incredible power of
the chaos emeralds you can summon a
storm of clones
uncover hidden secrets
and so much more
and for the first time in the series
local co-op is available for up to four
players
[Music]
combine your powers and take on the evil
Dr Eggman when Sonic Superstars Launches
on the Nintendo switch system this fall
[Music]
a cozy life is just around the corner
welcome to paleo in this free to play
Adventure Sim create the idyllic life of
your dreams alongside in-game characters
and players from all over the world
build houses decorate your home plot
throw crops in your garden and more play
with other residents in online co-op or
carve out your Blissful life solo
and if you're eager to explore there's
plenty of Life Beyond The Village
set off on a vast journey to uncover
palius many Mysteries or just kick back
and relax at home how you live is
entirely up to you
what kind of coziness will you choose
palea is free to play and Launches on
Nintendo switch this holiday
[Music]
ignite your heart
the Phantom thieves return in this
tactical spin-off of persona 5.
when the group ends up in an unfamiliar
World they must join forces with a
revolutionary named Arena to combat the
armies that have taken control
[Music]
during battle assess the situation and
determine whether to unleash an attack
up close from afar or using a persona
[Music]
knock enemies down to perform another
action called one more then surround
your foes and take them out with
dramatic Flair using the new all-out
attack triple threat
the fusion ability from the Persona
series returns allowing you to combine
personas to form other ones what is
Arena's true objective and what truths
lie hidden in This Strange World
a revolutionary tale will ignite when
Persona 5 tactica Launches on Nintendo
switch November 17th pre-orders for the
physical version of the game begin today
please check your local retailers
[Music]
step into a Saturday morning cartoon
calling all heroes for the first person
roguelike Adventure mid-force enter a
high fantasy world inspired by Saturday
morning cartoons of the past it's up to
you to stop the evil Daedalus from
taking over but it won't be easy
treacherous tombs and cryptic castles
threaten your survival wield medieval
weapons and legendary magic to Smite
hordes of monsters
during each run you can find treasure to
help boost your character's abilities
weapons and more
plus up to four Brave Heroes can share
the adventure in online co-ops drop in
and out at any time as you face the many
perils ahead by the power of teamwork
midforce Launches on the Nintendo switch
system this year
[Music]
this black vest is going to be pretty
sweet
[Music]
the next flat best for the Splatoon 3
game has been confirmed
okay squids here's the theme which
flavor of ice cream is best vanilla
strawberry or mint chip this black bass
will be held during the dates shown on
screen
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
these choices are delicious guide your
favorite flavor to Victory
plus get splatting in themed battles
with challenges
more splatastic events are on the way
be on the lookout for more info in the
future
[Music]
to promote an even stronger bond between
the people and Pokemon of rhyme City
[Music]
I hereby Proclaim this day the start of
Pokemon friendship week
Tim Goodman Pikachu
due to are the ideal detective Duo
disguises are a key part of detective
work quick goofing often investigates
so much for my coffee something tells me
this is just the beginning
the light roast today huh
[Music]
no no
there is something the two of you must
know based on our deductions the culprit
is clear isn't it a bunch of brilliance
the name's Pikachu and I'm what you
might call a great Detective
I sure wish somebody would bring me some
coffee
that was detective Pikachu returns
looks like he still loves coffee
what cases will Tim and this
tough-talking Pikachu solve together
more info will be revealed in the future
next please take a look at this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ly released on Super NES Super Mario RPG
returns with brand new graphics
whether you played the original game or
not why not take the opportunity to jump
into the very first RPG in the Mario
series
Mr koizumi that last trailer featured
Mario but he's not the only one getting
a game huh what do you mean
let's take a peek
that's right Princess Peach will star as
the main character in a brand new game
when she steps on this particular spot
on stage
huh
whoa what on Earth is happening
that's all we'll show for now we'll
share more details at a later date Mr
koizumi
there's actually something else what
here I wow
a visually enhanced version of Luigi's
Mansion Dark Moon originally released on
Nintendo 3DS is in development we hope
you look forward to seeing more of
Luigi's ghostly antics
yeah
both games will launch next year
Mario Princess Peach and Luigi looks
like Mario fans have a lot of games to
look forward to
more details will be shared in the
future
all right let's see some more headlines
become Gotham City's ultimate protector
wake up Mr Wayne we have much to discuss
I want you to know the fear that is
coming this
is the beginning of the end for you Dark
Knight
you're all going down
you still know how to make an entrance
welcome to the madhouse Batman
[Music]
I will command forces beyond your
comprehension
place is dangerous
make it
Gotham would be ours Over My Dead Body I
believe that was the idea
don't be a stranger you're always
welcome here
Arkham Trilogy launches a Nintendo
switch this fall
play your cards right mercenary
lead your mercenaries through cursed
dungeons in the lands of gloomhaven your
Tactical prowess is all that stands
between riches and certain death this
adaptation of the hit board game
features turn-based card battles with
RPG elements unleash deadly Combos and
bring Doom upon your pose but beware
exhaustion is close at hand choose from
17 different mercenaries Brave over 260
grueling missions and master over one
thousand abilities
hone your deck set up synergies and gain
every advantage to survive
grit your teeth and earn your keep when
gloomhaven Launches on the Nintendo
switch system September 18th pre-orders
for The Mercenaries and gold editions
begin today on Nintendo Wii shop
[Music]
keep the dance party going
for bad news
[Music]
move your lips
if you want it just like me
[Music]
[Applause]
a silent hope lies in a world without
words
one day a once peaceful round was
silenced by its king
now seven wordless Warriors will rise
in this action RPG these Heroes Bound by
Fate must work together to explore the
abyss and find the secluded King
however with its ever-changing Dungeons
and Powerful foes Conquering the abyss
will be no easy piece wield weapons like
swords bows magic and more to survive
this deadly chasm
after you return to base materials
you've collected will help you cultivate
resources and Forge new items
repeated parades into the abyss will
enable you to grow stronger and dive
deeper
your guide on this journey is the
Kingdom's sorrowful princess encased in
a crystal of her own tears and through a
mysterious power her voice reverberates
in the hearts of the silent Warriors why
did the king steal the world's words and
what awaits the Warriors in the depths
of the Abyss
silent hope Dives onto Nintendo switch
October 3rd
Sparks will fly in these Nintendo switch
games
cast spells and cultivate your best life
in Faith Farm
make use of magic to complete tasks and
fend off mischievous foes
enrich your farm to help your character
flourish
decorate your space to improve your
stats for the day ahead
and enchant your friends locally or
online in four-player Co-op Fey Farm
launches as a console exclusive on
Nintendo switch September 8th pre-orders
including an in-game bonus are available
now on Nintendo eShop
zoom into wild racing action with Hot
Wheels Unleashed too turbocharged choose
from over 130 vehicles and pull off
outrageous stunts to avoid obstacles
find shortcuts and knock your Rivals out
of the way Unleash Your creativity by
modifying your vehicles and building
your own tracks race locally with
friends in Split Screen Co-op plus up to
12 players can hit the track online grab
the wheel when this game speeds onto the
Nintendo switch system October 19th
get your chassis looking classy in manic
mechanics
[Music]
grab a part
fix it up
and toss it over
repair Vehicles quickly to earn points
in Solo play or for player co-op
but watch out for treacherous pits pesky
UFOs and other workplace hazards manic
mechanics launches first for consoles on
Nintendo switch July 13th pre-orders
begin today on Nintendo eShop
introducing the second paid DLC from
Mario plus Rabbids Sparks of Hope
Mario and friends journey to a musical
Planet
filled with new areas to explore and new
enemies to battle
what else will they find in this world
of melodies
this new DLC the last spark Hunter
launches later today
[Music]
a demo of the main game is available now
on Nintendo eShop
[Music]
you intend to take arms against me
you are now cursed unable to harm
monsters
you're going to have to become a monster
Wrangler
[Music]
one of us
let's roll
[Applause]
[Music]
ah the so-called hero is here
that was Dragon Quest Monsters the Dark
Prince from Square Enix
what kind of Journey will you take to
become the master of monster kind
please be on the lookout for more info
in the future next we have more news on
a certain game with plant-like creatures
welcome to the rescue Corps
as its newest recruit you'll venture to
a mysterious planet with all sorts of
life forms
there you'll meet plant-like creatures
called Pikmin
and the adorable rescue pup Ochi
boy
your mission should you choose to accept
it repair the damaged rescue core
spaceship and save any Castaways you
find alright let's explore together
[Music]
once plucked Pikmin are ready for action
blow your whistle to gather them and
have them follow you
throw your little buds at things and
they'll start working for you
Ochi will also prove to be a great
canine companion
he can carry items with Pikmin
or smash obstacles in your way
and if you need a flotation device well
[Music]
there you go
Ochi can even stand up to the wildest
creatures
collect lots of Treasures scattered
around the planet to fix the spaceship's
radar and open up new areas to explore
[Music]
exploration isn't limited to the surface
though why not take the plunge
Underground
here a completely different environment
awaits
unusual contraptions
native creatures
and even more Treasures are around every
corner
you might unexpectedly find some
Castaways too
[Music]
hey wait a minute
this leafy individual just nabbed the
Cast Away you've got to stop him
it's time for a dandori battle
[Music]
embrace the art of Dan Dori by
strategically issuing commands to your
Pikmin and Ochi collect more objects
than your opponent within the time limit
to win and Save The Cast Away
[Music]
by rescuing Castaways you'll be able to
do more activities back at base camp
which is right next to your spaceship
traynochian teach him new skills
[Music]
or build new equipment and items to help
make exploration more manageable
for the first time in the Pikmin series
you can eventually set out for night
Expeditions but there's a catch
Nightfall sends creatures into a frenzy
so stay alert
thankfully you'll come across the new
glow Pikmin which only appear at night
find luminals that produce valuable glow
sap these Mounds also attract various
Wildlife so use glow Pikmin to drive
them away and protect the luminals
many more surprises await on this
Uncharted planet
but with the Pikmin and Ochi by your
side no challenge is too big
or too small
thank you
Pikmin 4.
in past Pikmin games you had to return
to your spaceship before Sundown however
in this latest entry you can now venture
out at night
we hope you can lead the Pikmin on your
Expedition
[Music]
we have even more Pikmin news to share
the HD versions of the first two Pikmin
games originally released on Nintendo
GameCube will launch on Nintendo eShop
later today
plus ahead of the game's release a demo
of Pikmin 4 will be available on
Nintendo eShop on June 28th the demo can
be enjoyed even if you've never played a
game in the Pikmin series before so we
hope you'll try it out when it releases
okay let's see a few more headlines
the renowned series of stealth Action
games is infiltrating Nintendo switch as
Metal Gear Solid Master collection
volume 1. this compilation includes
Metal Gear Solid infiltrate and regain
control of Shadow Moses Island
Metal Gear Solid 2 Sons of Liberty
locate and retrieve a deadly amphibious
weapon Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater
survive the jungle and confront your
former mentor
you can also enjoy the games that
started the series metal gear and Metal
Gear 2 Solid Snake as well as the NES
versions of both metal gear and snake's
Revenge
this compilation also contains the first
Metal Gear Solid digital graphic novel
and its sequel
additional content includes screenplay
books and master books with story and
character info
strategy guides for each game and a
digital soundtrack
Metal Gear Solid Master collection
volume 1 Launches on Nintendo switch
October 24th pre-orders begin today on
Nintendo eShop the first three Metal
Gear Solid games will also be available
separately on Nintendo eShop
[Music]
it's time to survive
steal thyself vampire survivors is
coming to Nintendo switch do you have
what it takes to survive a 30-minute
onslaught of monsters
stay on the move to avoid enemies and
attack automatically with your weapons
seems easy at first right but swarms of
increasingly stronger monsters will
appear the longer you survive
by getting treasure chests from defeated
enemies or by leveling up you'll acquire
weapons and upgrades for your character
so shape them as you see fit plus up to
four players can now play together in
couch Co-op
and what other Horrors lie in store
find out when vampire survivors Launches
on the Nintendo switch system August
17th
[Music]
music and pigeons sounds pretty cool
you're a pigeon yeah you heard that
right
play online in this Rhythm Battle Royale
and aim to be the last bird standing up
to 30 players can ruffle each other's
feathers in musical minigames
copy the leader's actions perfectly in
yes commander
fire a slingshot to play music in first
piano shooter
[Music]
race and Fly To The Rhythm in to the sky
and more
with over 20 mini games you're in for an
impeccably good time
get ready to shake those pigeon Tails
when Headbangers Rhythm Royale Bobs its
way onto Nintendo switch October 31st
Ready Set
oh
penny is on the Run entangled in a
chaotic audition that veered Way Off
Script she's managed to make some
powerful enemies and a newly animated
friend in this 3D platforming Adventure
from the team behind Sonic Mania you'll
explore the bright and colorful world of
macaroon and how Penny and yo-yo escape
the clutches of The Grouchy Emperor
Eddie perform stylish acrobatic tricks
to avoid Eddie's massive horde of pushy
penguins and power up yo-yo to protect
Penny from Foul Play
you can also put your speed running
skills to the test in time attack mode
to unlock special items complete secret
stages and more this is your big break
after all take the stage when Penny's
big Breakaway Launches on Nintendo
switch early next year
rev up for wave 5.
a brand new course is racing into wave 5
of the Mario Kart day Deluxe Booster
course past DLC introducing squeaky
clean Sprint
more characters are also being added
from Mario Kart Double Dash PD piranha
from Mario Kart 7 Wiggler
[Music]
and from Mario Kart tour comic
wave 5 of the Mario karte Deluxe Booster
course pass DLC for the Mario Kart 8
Deluxe game zooms onto Nintendo switch
this summer
active Nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack members can enjoy this
DLC at no additional cost the DLC can
also be purchased on its own
[Music]
Two Worlds one Fateful Encounter
a remake of the second Star Ocean game
complete with new graphics that fuse 2D
and 3D is on the way
after a mission goes wrong Federation
officer Claude is stranded on an
undeveloped planet
there he meets Rayna who possesses
mystical Powers was it fate or mere
coincidence soon after the two get
entangled in a Sinister plot within the
Galaxy
in this science fantasy RPG select
either Claude or Raina as your hero and
play through the story from their
perspective you'll also meet over a
dozen potential allies from all walks of
life
during your adventure the hero you chose
and the decisions you make will have an
impact on who can be recruited to your
cause
battles take place in real time and
skills can be performed with a single
button
new combat features in this remake
include stunning enemies with chain
attacks
[Music]
having allies not in your current party
unleash follow-up attacks letting you
map out strategic battles in your favor
as you search for a way home an ancient
prophecy will unfold and your destiny
will be awakened
Save the Planet in Star Ocean the Second
Story R launching on Nintendo switch
November 2nd
[Music]
it's
it's time Wario Style
get ready for more micro game Mayhem in
the latest WarioWare game
foreign
[Music]
controllers then action
move your body to take on a flurry of
lightning fast micro games
what you do and how you move depends on
the micro game react quickly with the
right movement and you'll be on the road
to Victory excellent
if you've got two pairs of controllers
play with a friend in local co-op
sync up your actions to beat each micro
game plus up to four players can live it
up across various mini games and party
mode for example this dicey board game
is going to keep you on your toes
[Music]
get your body moving in over 200
Lightning Fast micro games
in warri aware move it launching on the
Nintendo switch system November 3rd
pre-orders begin today on Nintendo eShop
[Music]
why aren't you saying anything
so into it I didn't want to interrupt
anyway this is the latest WarioWare game
you'll use your entire body to strike
different poses and complete micro games
we have a few more things to share
[Music]
families can join the fun at Nintendo
live 2023 play games enjoy live
performances
take photos with some of your favorite
characters and more
plus cheer on your favorite players in
two championships eligible attendees can
also compete in on-site tournaments and
participate in a last chance qualifier
this all ages celebration is free and
will take place September 1st through
4th in Seattle Washington
registration for Nintendo live 2023 ends
June 22nd head over to the official
website and enter the random drawing for
a chance to receive tickets Pax West
batch holders interested in attending
can visit the official Pax West website
for more details those not selected will
have another chance to attend with the
three challenge cups this summer the top
10 players from each will get tickets
please visit the official website for
more details see you there
a vast number of players are enjoying
their time in Hyrule in The Legend of
Zelda tears of the Kingdom which
released last month
[Music]
thank you all very much
an amiibo figure of link from the game
was released to coincide with the game's
launch
new amiibo of Zelda and Ganondorf are
planned to be released this holiday we
hope you're looking forward to them
okay this next segment will be our last
announcement please take a look
[Music]
onward and upward
Glory
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
now
okay
go go go
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Zoe
well then
that was the brand new 2D side-scrolling
Mario game Super Mario Brothers Wonder
when you touch a Wonder flower expect
the unexpected the ground could start
moving
or you might turn into something
different for example
there were also flowers talking
Daisy is playable
and Mario became an elephant at the end
a lot of things happened we'll share
more details in the future so we hope
you'll look forward to it
that's all for today's Nintendo Direct
thank you for watching